[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend was robert habeck heute in
sachen atomkraft verkündete wird sehr
unterschiedlich aufgenommen
diejenigen die dafür waren die
atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
sind enttäuscht habeck will die
verbliebenen meiler noch nicht mal in
einem sogenannten streck betrieb
schicken nur als notreserve werden zwei
kernkraftwerke vorgehalten um sie bei
bedarf also notfalls wieder in gang
setzen zu können
das wiederum wird aber vielen grünen
bereits aufstoßen für die jeder tag über
das ausstiegsdatum hinaus schwer zu
schlucken ist immerhin die
wahlkämpfenden parteifreunde
niedersachsen werden erleichtert sein
dass der meiler im emsland da außen vor
ist der soll definitiv von max karl
hinterleitner berichtet heute abend vor
der bundespressekonferenz proteste von
umweltschützern gegen robert habeck ende
des jahres sollte endgültig schluss sein
mit der atomkraft in deutschland
doch das gilt seit einigen stunden so
nicht mehr denn man müsse bei der
sicherung der energieversorgung auch den
schlimmsten fall bedenken deswegen ist
die für mich richtige konsequenz aus dem
stresstest dass wir uns diese option
erhalten
nach dem ende der regulären laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke die beiden süddeutschen
atomkraftwerke in einer reserve
überführen so dass sie
wieder genutzt werden können oder weiter
genutzt werden können wenn die situation
ist gebietet diese letzten drei
atomkraftwerke sollten zum ende des
jahres vom netz nur der meiler emsland
wird auf jeden fall abgeschaltet
neckarwestheim 2 in baden-württemberg
und das bayerische isar 2 laufen wenn es
nötig ist bis april nächsten jahres
vertreter der deutschen industrie sind
eindeutig für den weiterbetrieb der
atomkraft
in einer so außergewöhnlichen situation
in einer kriegssituation wenn man das so
sagen will dass man hier auch manche
hürden überspringen muss um zu
verhindern dass wir in diesem winter in
eine existentielle energiekrise als
deutschland hineingeraten zwei meile
sollen ab januar im sogenannten
notbetrieb weiterfahren können also nur
dann wenn es für die versorgung und
erforderlich ist das und das enddatum
april sei zu wenig meint die größte
oppositionspartei
diese entscheidung ist ein rückschlag
für die energiesicherheit ist ein
tiefschlag für europäische solidarität
so zu einem aufschlag auf die preise
führen uns zu einer ausweitung der
klimalüge alle kapazitäten müssen
genutzt werden um einen energie-notstand
abzuwenden und mit dem was habig
vorschlägt werden eben gerade nicht alle
kapazitäten genutzt es wird er eine
reserve vorgehalten das ist nicht
konsequent des ist halbherzig doch auch
dem liberalen koalitionspartner geht die
heutige entscheidung nicht weit genug
habe es pläne womöglich auch an
stresstest für die ampel wir brauchen in
deutschland mehr sicheren aber wir
brauchen auch mehr günstigen strom
beides hängt miteinander zusammen
mehr günstiger strom heißt mehr
strommenge und dafür ist die
laufzeitverlängerung der drei am netz
befindlichen kernkraftwerke sicherlich
der richtige weg der wille zum ausstieg
steht zwar auch weiterhin durch die
konsequenz dabei gerät ins wanken
deutschland als vorreiter bei der abkehr
von der kernkraft das gilt seit heute
nur noch bedingt
und robert habeck ist uns aus berlin
zugeschaltet genannt der minister guten
abend wenn man sich das ansieht also
nicht mal streck betrieb wie viel stress
wird diese konsequenz die sie aus dem
stresstest ziehen in ihre koalition
bringen die fdp würde ja gerne wirklich
gerne sehr viel länger kws benutzen
muss trennen was der stresstest und
meine aufgabe im moment ist und fordert
das notwendige um die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland zu
tun das muss getan werden und das muss
auch getan werden und das werde ich tun
das ist meine verantwortung das was man
sich noch denken kann ist nicht die
aufgabe die jetzt ansteht sondern das
was die versorgungssicherheit
gewährleistet und alle anderen fragen
kann man im wahlkampf verhandeln aber
nicht in dieser koalition ich glaube da
sind alle klug genug führen ja aber die
reaktionen sind ja eindeutig dass sie
sehr wohl die versorgungssicherheit
gefährden würden das eigentlich ohne
noten aus ideologischen gründen
habe ich noch nicht gesehen ganz im
gegenteil ich halte das für eine
angemessene und kluge und auch genau
zielgenaue entscheidung wenn man sich
den stresstest anschaut sieht man dass
wir unter extremen szenarien vor allem
ein problem bei der netzstabilität
bekommen also nicht das was immer
behauptet wurde wir sparen groß gas
einen ganz im gegenteil und auch die
strommenge ist gar nicht unser haupt
herausforderung sondern es ist die
netzstabilität dort kann eine
vergleichsweise große lücke auftreten
wenn das ausland zu viel energie absaugt
zu viel energie frisst aus deutschland
und eben keine kapazitäten zur verfügung
hat und diese lücke kann durch die
atomkraftwerke in einem vergleichsweise
geringen anteil ungefähr zu einem achtel
geschlossen werden vor allem durch die
beiden süddeutschen atomkraftwerke und
das machen wir deswegen halten wir sie
vor aber die der stresstest sagt nicht
dass die atomkraftwerke weiter laufen
sondern nimmt ein ganz viele maßnahmen
zusammenhalt diese glücklich diesem wie
erklären sie denn dann dass die
netzwerkbetreiber die heute auch bei der
pressekonferenz mit ihnen saßen und die
er mit ihnen diesen stresstest und
zusagen ausgearbeitet haben wie erklären
sie sich dass sie so nachträglich
empfehlen und zwar dringend empfehlen
alle möglichkeiten zur stromerzeugung zu
nutzen und auf keine möglichkeit im
jetzigen zeitpunkt zu verzichten und
auch sagen die lage sei äußerst
angespannt oder in europa kann im
strommarkt die last nicht vollständig
getragen werden das klingt sehr viel
alarmistische als sie sich ausdrücken
nein ich bin wie soll ich sagen soll auf
die lage fokussiert aber die lage ist ja
jetzt angespannt unter bestimmten
annahmen jetzt die pegelstände im rhein
niedrig und die kohlekraftwerke werden
nicht voll mit kohle versorgt die
schiffe können nur halb beladen hören
jetzt hat es nicht geregnet und die
wasserkraftwerke haben nicht genug
größer war jetzt haben die franzosen nur
die hälfte ihres kraftwerksparks am netz
und der stresstest verlängert dieses
szenario in den winter und dann kommen
noch kalte tage dazu und die tage werden
kürzer und wir machen früher das licht
an aber die die annahme dass die
franzosen der return ist wir werden sehr
wohl die atomkraftwerke im winter alle
im betrieb haben mit einer gewissen
wahrscheinlichkeit kann man davon
ausgehen es wird irgendwann wieder
anfangen zu regnen das heißt dass der
stresstest prognostiziert sind
extremszenarien wir sind in der lage wo
wir uns darauf einstellen müssen aber
sind extrem sein die nicht wirklichkeit
werden müssen deswegen ist es politische
klugheit alle möglichkeiten
offenzuhalten das tun wir nichts
auszuschließen aber natürlich auch nicht
zu verdrängen dass atomkraft gerade
atomkraftwerke deren laufzeit ja
begrenzt ist teilweise
sicherheitsüberprüfungen jetzt länger
nicht durchgeführt würden eine
hochrisikotechnologie
eine abwägung aber wie könnte man das
nicht zwingend die aufgabe die
netzbetreiber aber sie haben wie könnte
man ja auch sagt er trifft man könnte
diese sicherheitsüberprüfung auch noch
weiterlaufen es geht ja auch nicht darum
zu sagen auf jahre hinaus also wenn man
sich eine bevölkerung umguckt und welche
umfragen ist da gibt's sagen zwischen
eine mehrheit die lage ist so kritisch
lasst uns doch diese meiler da was
länger laufen immerhin sechs prozent des
stroms kommt ja von den akw es
nur noch 6 prozent so muss man es sagen
und diese menge ist wir sind ein
stromexport land deutschland produziert
mehr energie als es selbst verbraucht
und das machen wir jetzt im moment für
frankreich und die
atomkraftwerke die beiden süddeutschen
können und der extremszenarien vor allem
ein beitrag für die netzstabilität haben
deswegen halten wir sie in der reserve
und nutzen sie wenn diese szenarien
eintreten und das ist ein sehr
transparentes vorgehen diese dieser
stresstest hat ja extremszenarien
hochskaliert also es wird immer extremer
und bei den extremszenarien da machen
sie ein unterschied ist können wir uns
jetzt schauen wir uns an wie sich die
wirklichkeit entwickelt und rechnen
runter ob für die atomkraftwerke
brauchen stichwort wirklichkeit
entwickelt sich und extremszenarien
rechnen sie damit dass wir von putin
überhaupt noch gas beziehen werden oder
hat sich das eigentlich hätte von
weitgehend erledigt es kommt noch ein
bisschen gas über die ukraine pipeline
aber das ist die einzige aufgemacht wird
gehört nicht zu den szenarien von dem
ich ausgehe es gibt ein anderes szenario
das die eu zum beispiel auch bei gas und
ölpreisen deckel gemeinsam macht also
eine art nachfrage kartell sehen sie
dafür eine realistische chance sie
fahren ja diese woche nach brüssel genau
am freitag ist der nächste
energieministerrat der werden wichtige
dinge verhandelt und hoffentlich auch
entschieden werden
ja die eu kann dort einen unterschied
machen man darf nur zwei sachen nicht
aus den augen wenn man einen preis
ansetze über den man nicht mehr einkauft
dann müssen trotzdem noch genug schiffe
nach europa kommen und uns beliefern
wenn er hoch genug ist dann würde das
funktionieren
aber wenn er nicht hoch genug ist dann
muss man auch wissen was man tut um gas
einzusparen und diese frage muss
beantwortet werden sonst kann man darf
man nicht drohen wenn man in der nicht
in der lage ist das auch umzusetzen und
die antwort habe ich jetzt auch noch
nicht gehört aber es ist eine das ist
eine idee kann der man arbeiten kann
arbeiten sie auch noch in einem
strompreis deckel wohl das eigentlich
auch nicht wirklich ein deckel ist
sondern abschöpfung und den verbrauchern
wird wieder was gegeben aber decke sagen
wir ja klingt aber irgendwie oder bremse
klingt ganz gut dann wird die denn am
klar definiert und welche mengen und in
welche preises da gehen soll nun der
nächste schritt ist der europäische
energieministerrat denn wir sind ja in
einem gesunden gemeinsam europäischen
strommarkt der muss auch zueinander
passen also deutschland österreich
frankreich
tschechien wir brauchen schon
vergleichbare systeme die für güte kann
unterschiedlich sein aber wir brauchen
die gleiche mengen findung über den
markt deswegen muss man da auch ein
bisschen aufpassen dass man nicht mehr
im hintern einreist was man mit den
händen aufbaut aber das geht jetzt mit
hochdruck voran und dass die idee ist
uns wieder auf die strompreise etwa auf
dem niveau zu bringen wie vor dem krieg
da wurden ja auch gewinne erzielt die
können etwas höher sein als ich mit dir
es nicht festgelegt werden zu sagen war
da landen wir aber die hohen zufalls
gewinne die durch die gaspreise dar
eingedrückt werden in dem markt die
müssen wieder raus
danke für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
das inter will haben wir aufgezeichnet
dass der kreml heute erklärte gas werde
erst wieder in vollem umfang fließen
wenn die sanktionen gegen russland
aufgehoben werden war ein interessanter
hinweis nicht nur darauf dass angebliche
technische lieferprobleme offenkundig
vorgeschoben sind sondern auch darauf
dass die sanktionen wohl durchaus
wirkung entfalten sonst bräuchte moskau
sie ja gar nicht ins spiel zu bringen
die große frage wird sein ob und wie
sehr es putin gelingt mit dem dasein als
waffe
europa und insbesondere deutschland
unter druck zu setzen und ob es der
bundesregierung gelingt mit ihrem
entlastungspaket gegenzusteuern
darüber gehen die meinungen naturgemäß
auch auseinander britta spiekermann
berichtet
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst in
niederbayern jackett aus ärmel hoch
volksfest gillamoos politischer
jahrmarkt die brüderlichkeit der
schwesterparteien cdu csu wird
beschworen gemeinsam gegen die ampel
regierung das entlastungspaket ja da
geht es gut es aber zu zögerlich zu kurz
gedacht und nicht abgestimmt
die länder sollen mitbezahlen was ja
scholz gestern versprochen hat markus
söder und ich habe nichts gehört vorher
mit uns hat keiner gesprochen für die
kleinen unternehmer für den
mittelständler für die handwerker für
die kleineren da wird nie was getan
immer das gleiche im neuen programm
fehlt alles scholz verspricht gestern
fiel lindner auf sogar die
schuldenbremse will der finanzminister
nächstes jahr wieder ziehen trotz
gigantischer ausgaben nicht zocken
entschlossen wirken auch wenn es gegen
den eigenen strich geht energiekonzerne
stärker besteuern geht also doch
seine erstaunliche wandlung die wir
gerade erleben erlitten hat vorher
gesagt dass er keine über gewinne
erkennen kann und jetzt sind es zuv als
gewinner also noch raider heißt jetzt
twix sonst ändert sich da nix neue
bezeichnungen sollen also neue
politische möglichkeiten eröffnen die
jetzt so genannte zufalls gewinn abgabe
will die ampel zeitnah europäisch lösen
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiges signal
auch in gerechtigkeitsempfinden der
bürgerinnen und bürger nur das problem
ist die regierung kalkuliert mit noch
nicht abgeschöpft gewinnen will damit
die strompreis bremse finanzieren das
ist weit mehr als eine unwägbarkeit
abseits dieser lücke finden
sozialverbände durchaus gefallen am
dritten entlastungspaket niemand soll
allein gelassen werden das hat die
regierung versprochen doch die
wirtschaft sieht sich genau auf diesem
weg haben gerade eine umfrage gemacht
mit 600 mittelständischen unternehmen
und da sind über 90 prozent die sagen
sie werden von diesen energiepreisen
stark oder existenziell beeinträchtigt
das sind zahlen die einfach klar machen
wie kritisch die lage in der wirtschaft
ist nicht nur die wirtschaft hat
gesprächsbedarf auch die länder haben
sich in position gebracht scholz muss
sie mit ins boot holen die länder
bestehen darauf wir haben verschiedene
punkte an denen sie sich auch mit den
ländern auszutauschen gilt und in soweit
ich kann noch keinen termin verkünden so
weit sind wir noch nicht aber die
anfragen laufen und es wird zeit nur
dann entschieden werden über allem steht
die drängende frage wer soll diese
entlastungen bezahlen das von der ampel
regierung so bezeichnete wuchtige paket
wartet auf mit einer wuchtigen rechnung
mehr hintergründe zum entlastungspaket
das ja wirklich viele unterschiedliche
themen umfasst finden sie bei uns online
auf zdf heute und mit europas energie
sorgen geht es jetzt auch in den
nachrichten erst noch mal weiter hand
deutschland und frankreich haben sich in
der energiekrise gegenseitiger
solidarität versichert der französische
präsident markus sagte nach einer
videokonferenz mit bundeskanzler scholz
dass frankreich bereits seit deutschland
mit gas zu versorgen
deutschland habe sich bereit erklärt bei
bedarf strom nach frankreich zu schicken
sechs jahre nach dem mutmaßlich
islamistischen anschlag in nizza hat ein
prozess gegen mögliche unterstützer des
attentäters begonnen er war am
französischen nationalfeiertag dem 14
juli mit einem lkw über die belebte
strandpromenade grasen 86 menschen
starben auch drei deutsche der
attentäter wurde von sicherheitskräften
erschossen
in kanada sind bei einer serie von
messerattacken mindestens zehn menschen
getötet worden 15 wurden zum teil schwer
verletzt die taten ereigneten sich in
einer ländlichen region in der provinz
sketche waren die polizei fahndet nach
zwei verdächtigen und sie bat die
bevölkerung auch in den benachbarten
provinzen um hinweise das motiv für die
taten ist noch unklar
in chile haben sich die gegner einer
neuen verfassung durchgesetzt knapp 62
prozent der wähler stimmten gegen den
entwurf der die verfassung aus der
kinokette ersetzen sollte sowohl gegner
als auch befürworter gingen nach der
abstimmung auf die straße die neue
verfassung hauptforderung der sozialen
protest von 2009 10 ging vielen
konservativen zu weit sie sah unter
anderem ein recht auf wohnraum bildung
und gesundheit vor dazu eine frauenquote
von 50 prozent in allen staatsorganen
und ein selbstbestimmungsrecht der
indigenen gemeinschaften
bei einem erdbeben im südwesten chinas
sind mindestens 46 menschen ums leben
gekommen und dutzende wurden verletzt
die suche nach verschütteten dauert noch
an durch die stöße der stärke 6,8 kam es
zu fels abgängen und erdrutschen straßen
in der provinz sichuan waren zeitweise
blockiert in einigen orten wurden
gebäude zerstört und die strom telefon
und internet versorgung unterbrochen
für seine kritiker ist boris johnson der
peinlichste premierminister den das
vereinigte königreich hat ein
notorischer lügner und clown so hoch los
wie verantwortungslos seine anhänger
hingegen nennen ihn den erfolgreichsten
politiker seiner generation und manche
werden vielleicht einfach nur bedauern
dass es in downing street number ten
künftig weniger unterhaltsam zu gehen
wird auch wenn sich seine nachfolgerin
lässt rus zuletzt sichtlich um den ein
oder anderen kalauer bemühte sie ist nun
also die neue nicht von den wählern ins
amt gehoben sondern von den mitgliedern
ihrer partei die wähler will muss sie
sich spätestens anfang 2000 25 stellen
wenn sie sich so lange im amt hält
andreas stamm berichtet aus london
das große ein und ausräumen hat begonnen
umzugswagen kommen und gehen im zentrum
der macht der auszug von boris johnson
erlaubt den einzug einer politischen
wandlungs künstlerin kurz vor eins ihr
moment
endlosen wochen des schaulaufens
470.000 tory mitglieder im rennen gegen
ex-finanzminister sulak die neue chefin
der konservativen lässt rus morgen
premierministerin vor ihr ein berg
probleme allen voran die explodierenden
energiepreise
wir müssen in den kommenden zwei jahren
beweisen dass wir etwas bewegen können
ich werde einen mutigen plan liefern mit
dem wir steuern senken und wachstum
schaffen ich werde liefern in sachen
energie krise und was die hohen
rechnungen der menschen betrifft
100 milliarden pfund wolle sie in die
hand nehmen innerhalb einer woche ihre
ideen publik machen weil jeder vierte
brite erwägt im winter die heizung
auszulassen energie armut betriebe bis
zum vierfachen für strom und gas zahlen
sollen pleiten bällen gefahr die art und
weise wie das trasse auf die
lebenshaltungskosten krise reagiert wird
entscheidend sein ob sie einen schnellen
politischen tod steht bis weihnachten
oder ob sie das land hinter sich
versammeln kann dafür muss sie muss ihr
ideologisches fällt tief in die tasche
greifen und neue schulden machen
genau das gegenteil was sie im wahlkampf
versprochen hat die herzen der
konservativen gewinnt rast durch ihre
inszenierung als wiedergeborene margaret
thatcher der partei ikone bildlich und
inhaltlich steuern senken weniger staat
das befördere wachstum die erste
wandlung also schon am tag bevor sie ins
amt kommt erst mal viel staat viele
schulden machen
gelernt ist gelernt miss anpassungsfähig
gestartet als liberaldemokrat hinwil sie
als junge frau die monarchie abschaffen
gewandelt zur konservativen geht 2010
ins parlament ab 2014 ständig wechselnde
regierungsposten bis zur außenministerin
unter drei völlig verschiedenen premiers
fleißig und flexibel wie bei ihrem weg
von der eu austritt gegnerinnen zur
verfechterin des harten rexit noch
härter gegen brüssel ein versprechen an
ihre partei dass die tür in die downing
street geöffnet hat sie aber einholen
könnte
durchaus möglich dass sie artikel 16 und
irland protokolls ausruft und einseitig
teile der mühsam ausgehandelten drexhage
vereinbarungen aufkündigt das wird in
der eu für enorm aufruhr sorgen aber
klar sie ist sehr anpassungsfähig was
ihre europa-politik betrifft mehr noch
sie ist flexibel was jeden ihrer
grundsätze betrifft
sie werde liefern liefern und nochmals
liefern erklärt sie am mittag im gefühl
des triumphs aber was eigentlich von
sievert es allen zeigen bis sie es
selbst nicht die meinung zur list rus
wie sie selbst äußerst wechselhaft und
wandelbar
im rückblick ist so vieles unfassbar was
vor 50 jahren bei den olympischen
spielen in münchen geschafft und auch
was danach alles nicht geschah erst das
versagen und dann das nicht reden wollen
über das versagen allein dass es nach 50
jahren immer noch aufklärungsbedarf gibt
und dafür jetzt eine
historikerkommission eingesetzt wird und
dass es 50 jahre gedauert hat bis sich
deutschland offiziell entschuldigt und
das präsident steinmeier tat das heute
sibylle bassler über eine gedenkfeier
bei der bis vor kurzem nicht klar war ob
die angehörigen der opfer und israels
staatspräsident
überhaupt teilnehmen würden
sie sind gekommen die angehörigen der
ermordeten israelischen olympioniken
nach 50 jahren trauer wut und entsetzen
sind sie zurückgekehrt an den ort der
unendliches leid für sie brachte im
fliegerhorst fürstenfeldbruck
erstmals erfahren sie wie anerkennung
auf die sie so lange gewartet hatten ich
bitte sie als staatsoberhaupt dieses
landes und dem namen der bundesrepublik
deutschland
um vergebung um vergebung für den
mangelnden schutz der israelischen
athleten
damals bei den olympischen spielen in
münchen
und für die mangelnde aufklärung danach
dafür
das geschehen konnte
was geschehen ist am 5 september
1972 drängen palästinensische
terroristen in der olympia dorf ein und
nahmen israelische sportler als geiseln
die geiselnahme endet mit einem blutigen
massaker auf dem fliegerhorst elf
israelis und ein deutscher polizist
werden getötet
von uns die sich an die finsteren
stunden unendlichen stunden im september
1972 erinnern tragen diese narbe im
herzen
bianchi spitze ihr mann andré war als
trainer nach münchen gekommen die
terroristen zwangen den jungen
familienvater sich vor laufenden kameras
am fenster zu zeigen es war das letzte
mal dass an die spitze in lebensjahr
danke andré für dein geschenk der liebe
ich bin so glücklich dass ich getroffen
habe du warst der wind unter meinen
flügen
mit ihren worten spricht sie vielen aus
dem herzen
am vorabend haben sich an die spitze und
die anderen familien der ermordeten
athleten vor der münchner synagoge
versammelt alle sind erleichtert ihr zu
sein doch eines sei klar so anke spitzer
france bis ans ende meines lebens wäre
ich ein loch in mein mehr
auch die angehörigen des getöteten
gewichtheber josef romano sind gekommen
es ist sehr hart wir warten auf diesen
moment seit 50 jahren aber wir werden es
nie vergessen
meine kinder endlich alle tragen ein
tattoo mit einer gewichtheber stange
dass die angehörigen gekommen sind dass
es eine einigung gab ist ihm zu
verdanken gerhart baum dem 89-jährigen
ist hier unmöglich es geglückt die
verhandlungen standen unter einem
gewissen zeitung aber sie waren nicht
einfach ich habe die dinge dann so
sagen wir mal auf die spitze getrieben
dass beide seiten nur noch ja oder nein
sagen
der heutige tag ein wichtiger schritt
nach 50 jahren gut mit den sitzen
[Musik]
und jetzt gibt es noch mal bei dir
weiterhin und noch mal mit dem thema
energieversorgung und den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen des
russischen gaslieferstopps durch die
nord stream pipeline war der real ab wie
wir die lage an der börse eingeschätzt
da das risiko dass die konjunktur in
eine rezession rutscht die war ja
ohnehin das war ja ohnehin schon groß
wenn sich die energiekrise jetzt aber
noch verschärft dann wird ein
wirtschaftlicher abschwung immer
wahrscheinlicher in der spitze ist der
gaspreis heute um mehr als 30 prozent
gegenüber freitag gestiegen und an der
börse hat dass ein beben ausgelöst von
dem sich der dax im laufe des tages nur
geringfügig erholte am ende mehr als 2
prozent - besonders belastet durch die
hohen gaspreise der versorger juniper
weil sich das unternehmen kurzfristig
mit sehr teuren erdgas eindecken muss
läuft es täglich hohe verluste an nicht
nur gas wird teurer auch der ölpreis
zieht an die allianz der ölexport
staaten opec hat beschlossen die
förderung zu drosseln weniger angebot
heißt höhere preise also auch da wohl
erstmal keine entlastung und jetzt
bringen wir noch kurz zum anderen thema
das viele betrifft stichwort home office
da gab es heute interessante zahlen
stimmt die pflicht zum home office ist
ja schon im märz ausgelaufen doch
arbeiten von zu hause hält sich
besonders im dienstleistungsbereich
offenbar setzen unternehmen und
beschäftigte dauerhaft auf das home
office laut einer umfrage arbeitete im
august fast jeder vierte zumindest
teilweise im home-office dass es kaum
weniger als noch im april
brave es so beliebt bleibt dürfte auch
von den energiekosten abhängen wer mehr
zeit zu hause verbringt muss für strom
und gas tiefer in die tasche greifen
aktuell bekommen arbeitnehmer einen
ausgleich für die extrakosten die
regelung läuft ende des jahres aus eine
verlängerung ist in planung aber noch
nicht beschlossen valerie hat vielen
dank
der waldbrand am brocken im harz ist
weiterhin nicht unter kontrolle trotz
erster erfolge sollen die löscharbeiten
morgen weitergehen
nach angaben der behörden brennt es auf
einer fläche von rund 150 hektar in zum
teil schwer zugänglichem gelände sieben
hubschrauber und zwei löschflugzeuge aus
italien unterstützen heute den einsatz
der 300 feuerwehrleute der brand war am
samstag ausgebrochen warum ist noch
unklar
in new york hat am abend juli niemeyer
das viertelfinale der us open verpasst
sie unterlag der weltranglisten ersten
liga-spieltag aus polen die 23 jährige
aus dortmund startet mit einem starken
ersten satz dann häuften sich die fehler
nach knapp zweieinhalb stunden musste
sich nie mal der titel favoriten
geschlagen neben 6 zu 2 4 6 und 0 6
das war es von uns gleich geht's weiter
mit der serie die tools und uns gibt's
am morgen wieder auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend inzwischen ist das tief pg
hier über den britischen inseln richtig
groß geworden und es wird es noch länger
beschäftigen
jetzt wird es erstmal schwül feuchte
luft heran treiben das bedeutet schauer
und gewitter und genau die gibt's im
westen deutschlands sind dieser nacht
auch im osten sind einzelne kleine
schauer nicht ganz ausgeschlossen meist
bleibt die nacht aber noch trocken bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 10 grad in
der uckermark und 18 grad am niederrhein
dieses west-ost-gefälle bei den
temperaturen bleibt uns auch tagsüber
erhalten am rhein werden noch mal 29 30
grad erreicht im nordosten bleibt es bei
20 bis 22 grad schon deutlich frischer
am vortag kann es an der nordseeküste
noch etwas stärker bewölkt sein da
reicht es vielleicht auch mal für ein
bisschen regen dann wechseln sonne und
wolken freundlich miteinander ab
nachmittags entwickeln sich vor allen
dingen über den bergen gewitter und dann
ändert sich das wetter denn das tief
peggy wird das hoch quentin immer mehr
nach osten verschieden und dabei
bekommen dieses kräftige tief peggy
unterstützung von einem ehemaligen
hurrikan das ist der ehemalige hurrikan
danielle den sie hier an der westgrenze
unserer karte gut erkennen können so ein
ehemaliger hurrikan bringt natürlich
nicht nur regen mit sondern auch viel
wind das sehen sie hier an der animation
für mittwochabend am mittwoch selbst
gibt es bei uns in deutschland schauer
und gewitter in einem streifen vom
erzgebirge bis zur nordsee danach aber
wird es deutlich kühler und regnerischer
endlich guten abend